porque creéis que donald trump tiene
tanto interés en castigar a la república
islámica de irán
[Música]
si habéis visto todos los vídeos que
hemos hecho en esta serie pensaréis que
su interés es subir los precios del
petróleo o ayudar a sus amigos de arabia
saudita o tal vez lo que quiere es
demostrar su poder ante la unión europea
pero hoy os voy a dar otra hipótesis
[Aplausos]
y si lo que realmente quiere donald
trump es acabar con el autoritarismo
irán no es ninguna teoría descabellada
irán está al borde del colapso económico
las protestas contra el gobierno son
cada vez más frecuentes y a diferencia
de otros países de la zona irán si tiene
una oposición secular liberal y
democrática es decir que no hace falta
librar una guerra con bombas tanques y
muertos para traer la democracia irán
bastaría con ahogar económicamente el
país para acabar con los ayatolás
[Música]
si este plan saliera bien donald trump
podría ganar el premio nobel de la paz
obama se la tendría que envainar y casi
seguro que volvería a ganar las
elecciones pero y si no se le da tan
bien de verdad el régimen de los
ayatolás es tan débil como pensamos
puede ganar esta apuesta donald trump en
este vídeo te lo vamos a explicar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
irán es el enemigo favorito de los eeuu
por ejemplo la casa blanca asegura que
las sanciones de trampa el país de los
ayatolás no buscan acabar con el régimen
pero hasta qué punto es eso cierto
[Música]
el asesor nacional de seguridad de la
casa blanca john bolton dice que eeuu no
quiere derrocar al gobierno de irán y
asegura que lo que washington quiere es
que las autoridades de teherán cambien
de actitud lo cierto es que desde hace
décadas eeuu ha intentado hacer todo lo
posible para acabar con el régimen de
los ayatolás
por ejemplo habéis oído hablar alguna
vez de radio free europe durante la
guerra fría el congreso de eeuu creó
esta radio para lanzar mensajes anti
comunistas en el bloque soviético hoy en
día esa radio sigue existiendo es más
tiene sus oficinas aquí en praga más
concretamente en el mismo barrio donde
vivo como unos diez minutos andando para
allá y en esta radio tienen todo un
departamento dedicado a irán con
programas y noticias en farsi
[Música]
es decir washington sí que están
interesados en que irán cambió su
sistema político otra cosa es si es
posible o si no es posible y os
preguntaréis de verdad irán es una
dictadura tan horrible a fin de cuentas
tienen elecciones y distintos partidos
políticos verdad pues la respuesta es sí
y no sí es verdad que los iraníes pueden
votar al presidente pero quién realmente
tiene el mando en este país es el líder
supremo el ayatolá jamenéi para que os
hagáis una idea
jamenéi es quien elige a la mayor parte
de los ministros tienen la última
palabra en política internacional y en
muchas otras leyes importantes
por supuesto las persecuciones a los
disidentes políticos son más que
frecuentes es más aunque existe un
movimiento importante de oposición al
régimen apenas hay líderes concretos y
porque no hay líderes de la oposición
pues porque todos están muertos en la
cárcel o en el exilio y algo parecido
pasa con los partidos políticos veréis
la política en irán es muy complicada y
en parte es porque los partidos
políticos son bastante débiles y por eso
normalmente se habla de facciones vamos
a hacer un resumen rápido para que nos
entendamos
por un lado está la llamada facción dura
son los que apoyan el sistema creado por
jomeiní hasta la última coma
es decir ley religiosa y con control
férreo del estado sobre la economía
[Música]
por el otro tenemos a la facción
reformista que son los que quieren
cambiar al régimen desde dentro como os
podéis imaginar a día de hoy la facción
reformista tiene muy poca influencia
y entre medias tenemos a la llamada
facción plasmática que es a la que
pertenece el actual presidente
hassan rujan y los pragmáticos están a
favor de mejorar sus relaciones con eeuu
y liberalizar la economía pero mantienen
cierto peso de la religión y ahora viene
la segunda pregunta de verdad es posible
que todo este sistema se venga abajo
pues lo cierto es que existe esa
posibilidad veréis cuando la economía va
bien es fácil mantener un sistema
autoritario muchos ciudadanos están
dispuestos a cambiar libertad por
bienestar pero en irán hace mucho tiempo
que desapareció el bienestar la divisa
iraní se devalúa día tras día y eso
lleva a una inflación brutal algunas
estimaciones no oficiales hablan de más
de un 100 por ciento de inflación para
este año 2018 y eso significa que los
precios cambian casi de un día para otro
muchos alimentos como el pollo están
empezando a escasear
[Música]
cada vez hay más miseria en las ciudades
y ni siquiera las privatizaciones que ha
hecho el gobierno van a salvar la
economía lo hemos contado ya aquí en
visual político 2018
empezó con protestas multitudinarias
contra el gobierno de rohan y muchos de
estos manifestantes eran jóvenes
universitarios que querían un cambio un
cambio hacia un sistema democrático
laico y secular pero la pregunta la
auténtica pregunta es es esto suficiente
para un cambio de régimen hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
una guardia pretoriana en el año 1979
comienza la revolución islámica de irán
el líder supremo por año entonces el
ayatolá jomeiní sabía que el ejército
iraní le podía traicionar en cualquier
momento
[Música]
tras décadas sirviendo al sha de persia
es difícil cambiar las lealtades de un
día para otro así que para evitar un
golpe de estado
jomeiní creó a su propio ejército
paralelo y así es como nació la guardia
islámica revolucionaria una especie de
guardia pretoriana creada para preservar
el sistema islámico al principio no era
más que un cuerpo formado por
voluntarios pero las cosas cambiaron en
los años 80
[Música]
por aquellos años irán entró en guerra
con irak y a quien enviaron para luchar
en este frente exacto a éstos
pretorianos que estaban dispuestos a
todo por defender sus valores
en tiempos de guerra las arcas siempre
están llenas para comprar más armas así
que día tras día esta guardia islámica
revolucionaria ganaba más influencia más
armamento y sobre todo más experiencia
para el final de la guerra irán-irak
esta guardia pretoriana contaba con más
de 130 mil soldados más otros tantos
cuerpos paralelos que dependen de ellos
[Música]
el día de hoy tienen hasta sus propios
servicios de inteligencia paralelos y
pueden hacer detenciones o seguimientos
sin ni siquiera tener que consultarlo
con el gobierno en otras palabras la
guardia islámica revolucionaria es el
pilar del régimen pero a la vez es un
régimen paralelo en sí mismo y por qué
son tan importantes veréis por muy mal
que vaya la economía es difícil formar
un movimiento de oposición cuando tienes
a un cuerpo de élite espiando a
cualquier posible activista político y
si hablamos de un cuerpo de élite
perfectamente entrenados para la guerra
híbrida moderna es más esta guardia
islámica revolucionaria también ha
combatido fuera del propio irán
[Música]
es hemos visto en siria irak o incluso
afganistán y en todos los casos los
expertos aseguran que tienen un
entrenamiento de primera y os
preguntaréis pero como pueden comprar
armas es decir seguirán estar tan
aislado del mercado internacional como
pueden armar a este ejército paralelo
pues veréis lo cierto es que desde hace
décadas irán tiene su propia industria
armamentística tal cual como lo es por
supuesto las patentes son chinas y rusas
pero los fusiles de asalto las balas y
hasta muchos vehículos de combate se
fabrican en el propio irán pero ya sé lo
que estáis pensando no les van a afectar
las sanciones económicas a fin de
cuentas si irán no tiene dinero tampoco
lo tendrá su ejército verdad pues mis
queridos amigos de visual política nada
más lejos de la realidad
[Música]
la presión externa y la falta de
competidores extranjeros ayudará a la
guardia revolucionaria a consolidar su
control sobre la economía de irán ali al
phone instituto de los estados del golfo
washington para que os hagáis una idea
un tercio de la economía de irán está en
manos de la guardia revolucionaria son
dueños de muchos monopolios estatales y
eso incluye a empresas petroleras
refinerías o constructoras por ejemplo
el 51 por ciento de irán telecom es suyo
si a esto le sumamos que están exentos
de pagar casi cualquier impuesto tenemos
que la guardia revolucionaria tiene una
economía totalmente sostenible y con un
ejército paralelo también entrenado y
también armado es muy difícil conseguir
un cambio de régimen pero si pensaba es
que esta es la única baza dirán estáis
muy pero que muy equivocados ahora mismo
lo vais a ver
si no acude al rescate lo hemos dicho ya
varias veces en otros vídeos de esta
serie china va a seguir comprando
petróleo a irán y lo cierto es que no
pueden dejar de hacerlo
china necesita torrentes de zumo de
dinosaurio y durante décadas irán es su
sexto proveedor más importante hablamos
de más de 800 mil barriles de petróleo
que llegan de irán todos los días con
esas cifras es muy difícil cambiar de
proveedores de un día para otro pero ya
sé lo que estáis pensando si habéis
visto los vídeos anteriores ya sabéis
que eeuu tiene un arma secreta para
evitar que nadie compre petróleo a irán
[Música]
hablamos de las aseguradoras básicamente
en ningún barco petrolero puede atracar
en un puerto si no está asegurado y casi
todas las empresas de seguros que
trabajan en el mundo del petróleo son
europeas o estadounidenses así que cómo
puede china seguir comprando petróleo
irán pues atentos
exclusiva china se pasa a los barcos
iraníes para mantener el flujo de
petróleo a pesar de las sanciones de
eeuu tal cual como lo es a falta
reaseguradoras irán se va a hacer cargo
del transporte y de todos los riesgos
que un barco petrolero se hunde irán
para que no puede llegar a su destino
irán paga y hay que cuidar el
mantenimiento de los barcos petroleros
irán paga pero aquí no se queda la cosa
pensadlo bien si el resto del mundo va a
dejar de invertir en irán qué es lo que
tenemos exacto
vía libre para la inversión china y eso
explica noticias como ésta
[Música]
una empresa china invertirá dos mil
millones de dólares en una refinería de
petróleo general lo habéis oído bien
china está aprovechando el vacío para
comprar todo lo que puede en irán es más
las empresas chinas también están
aprovechando las inversiones que han
hecho otras empresas por ejemplo total
es la petrolera francesa en 2016
comenzará la construcción de la que
sería la mayor planta de extracción de
gas natural del mundo ahora con las
acciones de trump es muy probable que
tengan que abandonar este proyecto y
quien está dispuesto a comprarlo exacto
china para que os hagáis una idea en
verano de 2018 el banco para el
desarrollo chino ha anunciado que dará
más de 15 mil millones de dólares en
préstamos para proyectos en irán y
diréis eso es mucho o poco dinero
[Música]
pues para que os hagáis una idea ya ha
servido para empezar a construir cinco
hospitales nuevos y que me decís de las
empresas recordáis que os decía que irán
es uno de los mayores productores de
coches de la región pues una de las
principales marcas del país
sai para ya ha firmado una 'joint
venture' con una empresa china que se
llama brilliance pero esperad un momento
porque esto es sólo el principio
[Música]
a ver cuál es el proyecto más ambicioso
que está llevando a cabo el gobierno
chino exacto la llamada nueva ruta de la
seda el proyecto one by one row esa gran
apuesta de xi jinping puedes adivinar
cuál podría ser uno de sus principales
nodos
[Música]
china pone los ojos se miran como un
importante centro para la iniciativa
belt and road por el momento ya están
renovando varias vías de trenes
la idea es conectar las principales
ciudades de irán con trenes de alta
velocidad para el transporte de
productos y diréis porque irán que tiene
de importante este país pues mira de
este mapa y lo vais a entender
imaginad un cargamento de teléfonos
móviles que viaja desde china pasa por
asia central y luego sigue por irán
hasta llegar a turquía se trata de una
ruta perfecta para que china pueda
enviar sus productos a europa por
supuesto que todo esto no son más que
proyectos y las empresas chinas ya están
teniendo más de un problema con sus
inversiones en asia central pero de eso
ya hablaremos en otros vídeos lo cierto
es que china está empezando a invertir
seriamente en irán significa esto que xi
jinping va a salvar la economía de irán
por supuesto que no pero será suficiente
como para que puedas sobrevivir el
régimen de los ayatolás pues
probablemente sí y eso explica que en
los últimos años las relaciones
políticas entre estos dos países sean
cada vez más fluidas
[Música]
xi jinping mantiene conversaciones con
el presidente de irán hassan rujano y
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros de
verdad creéis que las sanciones de trump
servirán para acabar con el régimen de
los ayatolás o más bien lo contrario
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y si queréis entender más a
fondo todos los detalles sobre las
sanciones nucleares a irán podéis ver
los últimos vídeos que hemos publicado
sobre este tema como siempre no olvidéis
suscribiros a visual político y darle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo darle a like
compartirlo con vuestros amigos y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]